grâce au travail mené pendant au cours
des dernières années des trois dernières
années par sa majesté le roi à travers
des émissaires à travers des contacts
directs à travers une implication active
aujourd'hui
ceci est couronné par une reconnaissance
par les etats unis la grande puissance
nos membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité l'acteur influent sur la scène
internationale une reconnaissance de la
marocanité du sahara et de la
souveraineté du maroc sur l'ensemble de
son territoire
y compris les provinces du sud
parallèlement à sa majesté a annoncé au
président que le maroc prendra des
mesures concrètes pour renforts pour
reprendre une relation avec israël sur
plusieurs niveaux à travers bien sûr là
les survols l'atterrissage les vols
directs sur la base de nos compte du
fait que le maroc a une grande
communauté juive marocaine qui vivent en
israël et qui a gardé un lien fort avec
le avec le maroc qui vient chaque année
célébrer les les festivités religieuses
et autres et familiale
7 dorénavant il y aura des vols directs
entre le maroc et israël
un bureau de liaison a été ouvert en 94
jusqu'en 2002 il sera réouvert pour
accompagner la dynamique économique et
la coopération technologique contrat
leader entre les deux pays présideront
de plus en plus de 19 ans championne